welcome to this video playing if you a
challenge here black player challenged
me to two games of three minutes with
two second increment and yeah you need
to be aware that this is blitz rating
that means it's different rating pool
and he's got a very decent five-minute
writing about 2,200 so he's just an
opponent that I could easily play
against in my regular five-minute games
is not weak by any means he just does
not play the regular um lets rating poor
too often my rating heared with 25 is
also very low normal players of my blood
strengths are normally in the splits
rating not the five min order prone half
ratings form of about 3,000 so this is
just a just a different yet discipline
if you if you want ok we have a Dutch
Dutch Leningrad and I'm preparing to
play e-form and I am not really sure if
black can yeah I can go here for now not
sure if I've is very weakening or even
losing upon right you cannot play five
and or this this means the spells
trouble if white manages to to play a
form in them and the Leningrad without
being being immediately punished in some
way he should be an in good shape okay
let's let's check you five if i take
here
hmm cannot take on d6 taking on d6 and D
if I forking what you can interpose with
the trade on d1 if I take you must take
with the bishop which is not ideal if I
take on e5 and it probably takes on the
form yeah very nice I mean jack it's a
good position and then in many ways not
sure about the most precise way to play
but this [ __ ] should keep something at
least that it will be a week pawn on e5
okay I just check it with Queenie to we
will play rook e8 problem is that better
way Queen d2 c3 could also be an idea
try to double against the pawn yeah
maybe do that Quincy three rookie three
rookie one just concentrating all heavy
pieces on the pond
rookie three rookie one we are not bad
maybe there was something better it
feels like I'm I should should have had
something more convincing yeah just
protects maybe I should have should have
prevented you form known okay if I it's
not terribly dangerous oh he's allowing
me to play age five if he takes rook f3
sir is irritating
okay maybe just to age 6 okay I can play
with 24 maybe Quinn to deform since this
I don't want to exchange Queens really
what if i if i switch it over to g4 and
this the chest might be an idea to h4
did I say gee form to h4 of course yep
don't want to trade queens running check
still not easy to avoid if I need to do
it I'd like to do it with the better
method terms pawn takes Queen 86 you
cannot take here because of rogue f3
yeah I go here kingi a team I threatened
rook h7 yeah but the creature 8 is not
helping at all Jaheim let's let's go
back and try to make some more headway
here be sure to see form
yep okay now that's the new weakness on
a six yeah I take cannot take here so
the rook here protect some now be five
is hanging and if he takes that is
Bishop c4 know Quincy for winning the
bishop so oh here check here we go it's
okay I've got b3 know this is the
colonel mate mate wait rucca each one is
also made not not so quick here ok just
make sure that is not meeting me this
could have easily happen Bishop c4 and
then then I'm checkmated note that we
have three minutes with two second
increment this means that I can be
relatively relaxed here 20 seconds is
plenty with two seconds increment black
resigned yeah this was probably more
difficult to play then it seems at first
because the the black king position is
slightly slightly weakened check chess
it's always always a bit bit annoying to
play maybe a maybe Queen D for him it
says this is the way to go let me pose
too much just briefly yeah this is what
you should do it's a check but it's only
a check really I thought here maybe but
you can't play b6 yeah this is this is
defensible I'd like to quickly quickly
check right right here if I have a
better continuation because this check
here is there's some better moves are 95
oh yeah this is in fact this is in fact
much better this I didn't think of ready
he needs to play rupee 8 de 95 this this
is very nice with this idea hmm yeah now
that's nice yeah i mean my continuation
it preserves something but it's not it's
not brilliant yeah it's a slight edge
but it's not spectacular alright thanks
for watching and the rematch is coming
right after that